Whoa! It's heavy.
See? The World.
We've got the world here.
We're going to blow up the world.
Sounds good, Right?
This is the fourth day of bang a week,
hope you're enjoying it so far.
We are. Well, I am.
I don't have to clear up all this, so.
I'm not enjoying it.
Dan's not enjoying.
It's pissing me off.
All right so, um.
Let's um
I think I'll like blowing up the world,
so should we do it?
Let's get rid of the world.
Right.
Pesky Earth.
Oh you're soaked.
Oh, blimey.
Jesus.
Oh man.
That was awesome.
I should have been further back.
Mental.
Did you reckon it was gonna blow up?
Idiot.
That was unbelievable.
I did not expect that.
You're like getting in
tight with the camera angle.
Yeah I was like get in here
and I got soaked.
Water was still coming down.
It was like upwards,
downwards, a tidal wave.
Oh look the glass is all
right inside somehow.
Oh, thank Christ.
Yeah.
Well, luckily
well we managed to find North
America pretty much intact.
Actually.
Yeah. That's my house.
And we found England.
That's your house.
But we've lost Scotland
and Ireland unfortunately.
The United Kingdom has been severed.
Shame, shame.
But at least we got Wales.
I think Newcastle's still
there unfortunately.
Oh no it's gone.
It kind of cuts off around Leeds.
If you're in Leeds, you've made it.
Yeah. Well done.
All right. Tune in
tomorrow for the big finale
of boom week.
You'll finally figure out what that
bloody hoop is doing on
the back of the tree.
You might be able to guess to be fair.
And the fact that I'm covered
in something or other.
Yeah, but don't mistake that.
Not this.
That is something different.
Yeah.
All right.
Follow us on Twitter.
Gavin Free, Daniel Gruchy
and check back tomorrow.
Yeah.
We'll see you then.